So we had a recorded vote on our colleague,
the MLA for Kirkfield Park,
his Bill on trans and two spirited day
a visibility important to know that our colleague is uh,
the first trans uh person,
first trans man ever elected in Manitoba's history
just in October of 2023, an extraordinary moment for Manitoba.
And so today's vote, recorded vote
to stand up in the house and show your support for trans manitobins,
for two spirited manitobins. Again,
we're also in in the,
the start of Pride Month and it's an opportunity to show manitobins,
all manitobins that they're valued,
that they're respected,
that we've got compassion,
that we have love and that we will always stand with Manitobans.
And two spirited Manitobans,
the member for Steinbeck, the member for Borderland,
the member for LA Verandre and the member for Springfield Rashad
all got up in the house and stood up and voted against Manitobans,
voted against Trans Manitobans,
voted against two spirited Manitobans.
They have trans and two spirited constituents in their constituencies
that they represent, that they're elected,
that they're paid good money to represent
in this Manitoba Legislative Assembly.
They do,
those four men got up in the chamber and voted against some Manitobans
humanity. They didn't even see them enough or respect them enough
or care about them enough
or have compassion enough for them
or see them enough to vote for their humanity.
That's a sad day for Manitoba history here.
And as I've always Said about the PCs when they show you who they are,
believe them. For the last eight years
they have shown us over and over and over and over and over again
including a mere couple of hours ago who they are.
As the minister responsible for gender equity,
for the minister responsible for uh our 2S LGBTQI relatives,
I am the minister responsible
and I take great exception to those four men
getting up in the chamber this morning
and voting against their humanity.
It is shameful and I hope that they'll do what's right and apologize.
We have an ongoing savage genocide against indigenous women,
girls
and two spirit across our territories from coast to coast to coast
because for generations
people who sat in these very rooms
in that very chamber didn't think much about indigenous women
girls are too spirited,
didn't give consideration to the Protection of indigenous women,
girls and too spirited.
If you're gonna run for office and you're gonna get elected,
you should care about all of your constituents
and you should be actively working against harm
so that when you come to estimates
and you ask the minister responsible about m m
I W G2S and what she's doing on 24 7
make the connection
that what happened this morning is connected to that violence.
There is consequence, there is deadly consequence
when you have people elected like the member for borderland,
the member for Steinbeck,
the member for Laver Andre and The member for Springfield Rashad,
who cannot even get up and support
and vote in favour of a Bill that gives humanity to trans
into spirited Manitobans and then to double down on it.
The member for uh, Laverandre just double down in the hallways.
He doubled down on that hate and that discrimination
and that real harm. So,
to me, it's like,
it's quite insulting that on the one hand,
members opposite are asking me about m, m,
I, W,
G, and on the other getting up to support harm.
The member for Portugal
Prairie sat on the committee for my colleague's Bill.
And the member said that he was deeply moved,
deeply moved by what he heard.
And yet
he still let his caucus vote in a way that show disrespect and harm
and hate and disregard. You can't on the one hand trying back track,
but you, you signed on to it,
you got elected. And then,
and then on the other hand,
sitting committee and say
you're deeply moved by hearing Manitobans
who came to present at committee,
who shared their heart, their spirit,
their lives, their experiences,
their joys, their pain,
their trauma. You can't sit through that
and then sit in a caucus with four individuals that we know about
and be okay with that.
There were many that weren't there that didn't vote.
Was that strategic?
Probably. Who knows?
We're talking about violence against women.
We're talking about violence against children.
We're talking About too spirited.
We're talking about m, m,
I, W,
G2S here this afternoon. You cannot disconnect those questions
from what happened in the chamber
this morning. They are intimately connected.
They are fundamentally connected.
And it really is quite disconcerting that the member for Portage
La Prairie will sit here and say that he's in support
and was moved by Manitobans,
but at the same time
be perfectly okay with his four caucus members and possibly more
voting against the humanity of Manitobans.
It just doesn't jive.
The member for Dawson Trail said that this was about shaming.
This isn't about shaming anyone.
This is about pointing out what
elected members in the Manitoba Legislative Assembly,
what they stand for. Talk about shaming.
I don't care if that's what you wanna do,
be you, do you whatever,
but live with the consequences.
There are consequences when we participate in harm.
And the consequences is that
from now until the day I am no longer elected,
I will never let every single member of the PC caucus
forget what they did during the 2023 provincial election
and what they did this morning on May 30th, 2024, ever.